Oh
no Raperonzolo Ma sei
tu che carini che sono a me queste cose
commuovono tanto rzo Hai sentito cosa ha
detto la mamma no
Pulisci trasformerò questa zucca in una
bellissima
carrozza
Wow piedi di peli
di un piede peloso e
[Musica]
puzzol Ah che bello stare in mezzo alla
natura Ehi
[Musica]
ma quello è Raperonzolo Oh Raperonzolo
mia Raperonzolo che cosa ci fai lì
Principe sei venuto qua a salvarmi dalla
mia Torre Lanciami pure i tuoi
bellissimi capelli e mi arrampicherò
verso di te per salvarti aspetta
principe ci penso
[Musica]
io ha lanciato i capelli adesso salgo
dai sbrigati Prova a
salire Oh
oh oh no eh
Ops ma non sei la vera Raperonzolo Ma no
non sono Raperonzolo Sono Anita non lo
vedi scemo era una parrucca dobbiamo
salvare questo cartone presto
sbrighiamoci Buongiorno Sei tu la
principessa raperonsolo Questi sono i
suoi capelli Eh sì sì Mi stavo giusto
giusto a poco preparando Ah bene allora
andiamo Ma no che non sono io io sono
Vitale Ah bene Io sono la guardia del re
e dobbiamo trovare la principessa
Raperonzolo è stata rapita dalla
matrigna cattiva quando era piccola e
dobbiamo trovarla subito e perché è
stata rapita perché i suoi capelli sono
magici hanno il potere di far
ringiovanire per questo servivano la
matrigna cattiva e lei l'ha rapita
dobbiamo andare a salvarla subito ti
aiuteremo noi a trovare la vera
Raperonzolo solo così potremo salvare il
cartone ma prima dovete aiutarmi a
uscire da qua devo riuscire a scappare
da questa torre e dalla matrigna
aiutatemi voi e lei chi è È la mia
fidanzata Anita non è Raperonzolo bene
ci aiuterà anche lei tranquilla ti
Salviamo noi Ah andiamo a salvarla
Allora idea Ho un'idea
andiamo Ah grazie alla Magia dei capelli
di Raperonzolo sarò giovane per
sempre Eccola quella è Madre gotel madre
gotel Sì È giovanissima Te l'ho già
spiegato prima sta usando la magia dei
capelli Ah è vero è vero guarda guarda
c'è Italy La vedi sì dobbiamo salvarla
Sì dobbiamo salvarla Come facciamo però
dobbiamo trovare un modo per distrarre
la matrigna E come faremo ci penso io
userò un balletto una poesia così la
farò innamorare di me e la sedur Ottima
idea Ottima idea Vai vai tu stai qua e
chi si muove sto qua Bravo bravo madre
gote Chi sei tu guardatemi da questa
angolazione posso ammirare meglio la
vostra
bellezza l'ha distratta bravissimo
adesso posso andare reita la mia
bellezza continua Sì perché tu sei
talmente bella che nulla può incf fronto
a te una stella e sei così bella che ti
penso dalla sera alla mattina sei la mia
regina e questi sono per te Per me sì io
adoro essere Ammirata e Allora
balliamo è un onore poter ballare con te
vai
tempo
cambio sei anche
bravissima Ti amo alla
folleria Ma la guardia del re Poverina
non possiamo lasciarla qua Non ti
preoccupare ci avevo già pensato adesso
ci penso
io i capelli di
Rano scappiamo scappiamo Grazie
è
scappata Grazie per avermi salvato
bravissimi e se non mi ricordo male
nella fiaba di Raperonzolo dobbiamo
trovare Innanzitutto la vera Raperonzolo
e poi trovare il suo fidanzato FN Forse
così riusciremo a salvare il cartone e
salvare anche Raperonzolo può essere in
pericolo andiamo dobbiamo stare attenti
agli scagnozzi della regina Ok ma
useremo il libro per orientarci Questo è
il mio nuovo libro voi ce l'avete
dobbiamo trovare la vera Raperonzolo
presto dai andiamo allora andare di qua
cerchiamo Ah non vi ho ancora
ringraziato per avermi liberato dalla
matrigna si stava innamorando di me
Davvero Eh sì sembravate veramente
innamorati dobbiamo cercare Rapunzel non
perdiamo tempo Grazie a te per averla
distratta Altrimenti non sarei mai
riuscita a scappare da quella Torre
andiamo
bro sento che Raperonzolo potrebbe
essere qua nelle vicinanze guardiamoci
bene intorno non vedo niente io qua però
potrebbe essere in pericolo Guardate
laggiù è lei sì era per onolo è lei sì
avviciniamoci presto sì
[Musica]
Sì eccoli
lì cosa stanno
facendo mi hanno ingannata e per questo
me la pagheranno Raperonzolo Raperonzolo
sei tu Sì sono io ma voi chi siete Io
sono la guia del re e loro sono due
ospiti nella nostra fiaba devi fidarti
di noi dobbiamo portarti dei tuoi
genitori ti stanno cercando da tanto sì
devi venire con noi ma davvero Grazie ma
prima di riportarla dai suoi genitori
dobbiamo trovare il suo fidanzato Flynn
solo così che riusciremo a risolvere la
storia del cartone quindi mettiamoci
subito in viaggio alla ricerca cerchiamo
FL quindi venire con noi Raperonzolo
Aspetta però aspetta Hai i capelli
troppo lunghi potrebbero riconoscerla
Però possiamo nasconderli con questa
giusto se nascondiamo i capelli di
Raperonzolo con questo cappello non
rischiamo che qualcuno ci riconosca e
provi a rubarle i capelli o a rapire
Raperonzolo andiamo non abbiamo più
tempo
Ahia
Ah io grande Flynn oltre a essere un
bravissimo ladro sono anche un
bravissimo spadaccino e ora mi sto
allenando per andare and a salvare la
mia raper Onzo Ahia
[Musica]
Ah indietro quello potrebbe essere uno
scagnozzo della matrigna state attenti
Ma no credo proprio che quello sia fnn
l'abbiamo trovato riconosci presto
avviciniamoci a
lui FL Ehi Voi chi siete Che cosa
volete Aspetta aspetta Ora ti spieghiamo
Noi siamo qua perché ti abbiamo portato
la tua raper
Sì sono io Raperonzolo Ma come
Raperonzolo Non puoi essere lei non ha i
suoi lunghi capelli dorati presto
Raperonzolo Mostra i tuoi bellissimi
capelli
[Musica]
dorati Raperonzolo Ma sei tu ti stavo
cercando Anzi mi stavo allenando per poi
venire a cercarti anche io ti stavo
aspettando
FL
Oh Che carini che sono a me queste cose
commuovono
tanto devo aspettare il momento giusto a
costo di tagliarli quei capelli devono
essere solo miei adesso che ci siamo
trovati possiamo stare insieme per
sempre per
sempre
rapolo attenta i suoi capelli devono
essere i miei devo andare intervenire No
aspetta Lascia che ci pensi FN Sì non
l'avrai mai non sarò più tuo prigioniera
matr gotel il tuo incantesimo ora è
finito ora sono libera No cosa state
dicendo che succede l'incantesimo la mia
giovinezza sta sparendo l'incantesimo
sta svanendo no no no no cosa è successo
i miei capelli No no
No l'avete fatto sparire la Matri la
matrigna è stata sconfitta ora potremmo
andare a vivere assieme Grazie anite
vitale per aver salvato Raperonzolo
Grazie a voi per averci aiutato a
salvare il cartone Adesso possiamo
finalmente andare a vivere insieme
Grazie ancora adesso mia dolcera
peronzolo
andiamo io li seguirò dovrò proteggere
la principessa A presto Ciao grazie
ciao
presto dobbiamo subito andare al secondo
cartone ci manca ancora un cartone da
salvare Pronti Via
Via Anastasia
Genoveffa Anastasia Genoveffa dite
immediatamente a Cenerentola di scendere
qua Il cammino è ancora sporco e lei
deve
[Applauso]
ripulirlo
Eccomi eccomi Anastasia e Genoveffa Che
cosa c'è Cenerentola non voglio vedere
neanche un briciolo di polvere Mi
raccomando deve essere splendente Uffa
ma devo ancora
pulire e se provi a lamentarti dovrai
pulire pure la cucina alzi fallo
comunque
E va bene Hai sentito cosa ha detto la
mamma no
pulisci fallo bene Non bisogna vedere
neanche un granello di polvere
sguattera Uffa sono capitata nel cartone
di Cenerentola e a quanto pare sono
Cenerentola il problema è che non c'è
Vitale non so dov'è finito lui mi
raccomando Sbrigati a pulire tutto e non
scocciare Sì sì ora mi
sbrigo E ora come faccio a uscire da
questa situazione non posso rimanere
Cenerentola e pulire i can mini per
tutto il tempo devo salvare il cartone e
devo trovare Vitale cliccate mi piace
qua sotto per portarmi fortuna e mi
raccomando Cenerentola Pulisci bene e
soprattutto non
scocciare la porta hanno suonato
Andiamo Chi sarà mai ha arrivate a
Piano
[Applauso]
Salve C rcca porto un un messaggio dal
signor principe il
[Applauso]
principe Ma prego Si
andiamo dai caro Dicci tutto Dicci dicci
Siete tutte invitate al ballo del
re che si terrà stasera perché deve
cercare una moglie per il suo figlio
principe Sono io sono io sonoo più bella
guarda che cuscia matila io invece ho il
sorriso migliore ma sei tutto rossetto
sui denti Ma aspetti che puzzi sono io
la più bello non credo proprio cara
Posso venire anch'io al
ballo
immaginatela col principe quabit Ma dove
vuoi
andare continua a Pire il camino che è
meglio Ma l'hai sentita
[Musica]
conto io io devo andare e ci vediamo
stasera al palazzo del cci belle ma io
sarò tanto la preferita del principe non
credo proprio sarò io la più bella
sarebbe stata la mia occasione quella
del ballo per vedere se c'era Vitale Ora
come farò a
[Musica]
ritrovarlo Guarda quanto siamo belle
Cenerentola il principe si innamorerà
sicuramente di una di noi non possiamo
di certo portarti con noi Ci faresti
fare una brutta figura sei tutta vestita
di stracci per carità rimani qua a
pulire Noi andiamo senò si fa tardi ciao
ciao
cia Forse non riuscirò più a incontrare
Vitale non riuscirò a salvare questo
cartone aspetta Ho
un'idea Eccolo qua nel mio libro ci sono
le parole segrete e l'alfabeto segreto
vediamo se c'è un aiuto per questo
[Musica]
cartone Eccola qua questa è una parola
segreta che potete tradurre con l'al
Faeto segreto che trovate dentro il mio
libro mettete pure pausa e traducete
questa
parola ho capito che parola è Ciao
Cenerentola Sono la fata madrina fata
madrina sei qua per aiutarmi certo non
preoccuparti Centola ti aiuterò io
Innanzitutto trasformerò questa zucca in
una bellissima
carrozza ma oh no od dimenticato di
caricare la bacchetta e ora come
facciamo la batteria è al 2% è scarica
però aspetta con il 2% posso fare
l'ultimo incantesimo Ok
[Musica]
B
Wow È bellissimo grazie fatamadrina
Ma ora come faccio ad andare al ballo
guarda le scarpe
cara
Ma queste non sono le scarpette di
cristallo di Cenerentola No cara ma con
quelle riuscirai a correre fino al
palazzo Ma ricordati a mezzanotte
l'incantesimo svanirà Corri corri Ok
vado subito Grazie fatamadrina
[Musica]
Sento della
musica deve essere quello il palazzo del
reo
[Musica]
vicinissima Eccolo è questo è il palazzo
del re presto andiamo al ballo Eccomi
sono qua per il ballo del principe prego
Madame
Wow È bellissimo questo ballo ma dove
sarà il
principe
[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma quello è vitale quindi Vitale è il
principe azzurro in questa fiaba devo
assolutamente avvicinarmi e spiegargli
quello che sta
[Musica]
succedendo
[Applauso]
bellissimo mio mio tutto
mio Benvenuti tutti al Gran palazzo del
re per questo ballo e principe vieni qua
Guarda non ti piaccio Guarda
qua cosa stai dicendo vai via Oh il
principe balla con me per favore che
Comm meti prego vai via vai via tu vai
via tu vai tu prendi me prendi me
Andiamo nella sala da ballo Andiamo
andiamo
meall
[Applauso]
principe
Princi siamo
bellissim insieme mezzanotte meno un
minuto Vitale è troppo tardi devo
scappare
[Musica]
aspetta Basta
silenzio Chi è quella ragazza che è
andata via Granduca vado a raccogliere
subito quella scarpa e domani alle prime
luci dell'alba scenda giù in paese e
scopra a chi appartiene quella scarpa
vada subito Sarà
[Musica]
fatto
Ah quel principe Veramente io non ho
parole pessimi gusti io mi sarei
innamorata di me stessa
subito vuoi dire di me ma ti sei vista è
rivestita come una pezzente Ma smettila
Comunque io sono più bella oh basta
litigare Lo sappiamo che sono io la più
bella io sono più giovane Uh ma io sono
più aggraziata non credo proprio Invece
sì no sì no sì no
sì La porta è il principe andiamo ad
aprire Si è accorto finalmente della mia
bellezza è la mia oh non è il principe
il duca
Buongiorno come molto probabilmente
sapete devo ritrovare la ragazza che ha
perduto questa Scar è mia è
mia mia Mi ricordo benissimo l'ho
indossata alla festa ora lo vedremo
sedetevi pure forza inizio io vi
mostrerò a tutti che questa è la mia
scarpa Sì
[Musica]
sì adesso adesso l'ilo inutile che
insisti Non è la tua e invece ti dico di
sì certo che sapendo che doveva venire
il duca potevi almeno lavart i piedi eh
E tu potevi lavart Eli i capelli ma mica
devi controllare e mettere la corona
quello Ma stai
zitta Aiutami No
dai lontana questo piede puzzolente Mi
dispiace informarla che non sembra la
sua signorina Te l'avevo detto che non
era la tua Adesso tocca a me
sì Tanto lo sappiamo che non sei
tu vieni qua l'idea qua ma era l'altra
[Musica]
scusi ma come ma non mi sta neanche Non
entra neanche l'
l'
detto No ha sbagliato scarpa vi faccio
provare ancora un po' mly qua meraviglia
Non sembra neanche la sua c'è qualcun
altro in questa casa
No no Nessuno che mi possa colpire un
fulmine in questo momento non c'è nessun
altro Quella è la mia scarpina cioè
scarpona cioè scarpa da tennis
prego prego provi anche lei la scarpa Ma
come ha fatto Cenerentola ad andare al
ballo deve essere stata la fata madrina
la fata madrina andiamo a rubarle la
bacchetta Sì
andiamo sarà un gioco da ragazzi sta
anche
dormendo non ti svegliare non ti
svegliare
andiamo
prego provi subito la
scarpa piedi di peli di
pu Che
schifo Ah che schifo un piede peloso e
puzzol Ah che schifo che cosa sono
questi
pi
hai visto C rettola ora so che ti starà
la
scarpetta e dei piedi
pelosi Oh no come faccio adesso forse
non riuscirò a salvare questo cartone e
con questi piedi poi non riuscirò
neanche a raggiungere
Vitale Ehi ma quella è la mia banchetta
Eh oh Anita Ma cosa ti hanno fatto ci
penso io Bil body di
Bo Grazie f matrina e a voi brutte OC B
body di
Bo
ah siamo prontissime Cosa sono queste
buffe ah Che
vergogna andiamo
Ma è lei è lei la ragazza che il
principe stava cercando
ma
principe ma Anita Vitale Ecco tu
finalmente Finalmente ti ho
trovata abbiamo risolto anche questo
cartone Sì abbiamo vinto la Challenge
Che bello ce l'abbiamo fatta ma cosa ti
sei messo e il capellino principe eh voi
cliccate Mi piace Mi raccomando se non
avete visto il primo episodio cliccate
subito
[Musica]
qua